[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Thank you for coming.
We have a really
important topic here today
for the Talks at Google.
It's my pleasure to be
able to introduce and emcee
the next hour with Kyra Kyles.
She's here to talk to us
about a very important topic.
One of my colleagues
actually heard
her speak at a conference, and
we felt compelled to really
help broadcast the message--
"Diversify or Die,
Why News Media Need
to Reflect Their Audience."
What we'll do is
we'll hear from Kyra,
go through the presentation.
We'll have a discussion.
I'll ask a few questions.
We have some open
mics for a lively Q&A.
To tell you a little
bit about Kyra,
she is the co-founder of
Myth Lab Entertainment.
She founded this
company with her sister.
It's a multicultural
agency, multi-platform.
She's also the former
editor-in-chief
of "Ebony" magazine.
So without further ado,
please welcome Kyra Kyles.
[APPLAUSE]
KYRA KYLES: Good
morning, everyone.
How are you?
AUDIENCE: Good.
KYRA KYLES: Good.
Wonderful.
So thank you so much for
the warm introduction.
And it's really
great to be here.
I really appreciate
people coming out
to talk about a topic that
is extremely important to me.
As Natalie mentioned, I've
been in the journalism industry
for about 20 years.
And it's interesting
that the industry
has changed in so
many ways, especially
as it pertains to technology
and the advertising models.
But there is one area where I
feel that it's woefully behind,
and that's why I'm here
with the daunting title,
to "Diversify or Die,"
because sometimes you
have to scare people in order
to make them make change.
So we're going to go with
the "Minority Report" now.
So just to give you a little
bit more detail about me.
I did work at "Ebony"
magazine, where
I was the editor-in-chief
and also the senior vice
president of digital editorial.
And honestly, that is the
first black-owned company
that I worked for.
And "Ebony" is an
interesting story,
because this is a
70-plus-year-old company.
And the reason it was
started is because, even
back then, of course, there
was a dearth of positive news,
or affirming news, or
even just factual news
about African-Americans.
And it's sad to me in a way that
something like that is needed.
I mean, we obviously
love it, and we're
excited about that and other
black-owned and black-run media
entities.
But the fact is, this
problem predates most of us.
And it still continues.
I also have had the
benefit of working
with a lot of
mainstream outlets.
And that's what gives me some
perspective in terms of I
came from "Tribune."
I worked with "The Sun-Times."
I've worked with vibe.com.
Worked with a number of dailies.
And even in college, it
was already obvious to me
that there was a
majority of white males,
to be honest, at these places.
And because of that, there
was a certain perspective.
None of this, I
think, is malicious.
I don't think it's
done to X anyone out.
But there are just certain
factors that are affecting us.
And I think we have to
be cognizant about it,
not only as participants,
like someone like me,
but our audience, someone like
you, and that you're empowered
here at Google to be able
to do something about it
because you're such a huge
factor with the media industry.
So I'll tell you a
little personal story
about how I figured out,
really, that I could never,
never, never leave the
journalism industry because--
I don't know.
There are so few of
us, we feel compelled
to remain within it, even
though it can be very brutal
and punishing at times.
We're losing ad revenue.
We're losing people many times.
But this is one of
the reasons why.
So Hurricane Katrina, I was
in the newsroom at the time.
And I was one of a handful of
African-American journalists
where I worked.
Most of the black people,
to be quite frank,
that worked there were
in the secretarial pool,
administrative, security.
There were not very
many black journalists.
So one day I was called down
to the big boardroom, you know.
And I was kind of
intimidated because I'm
thinking, typically,
the big editors
don't call down, like,
an editor or a reporter.
At the time, I was a columnist.
What on earth did I do?
So I'm thinking, did I write
something wrong in a story?
Is there a bunch of people
with pitchforks waiting for me
outside?
Like, what happened that they're
calling me into this room?
And what happened is it was
Hurricane Katrina had hit.
Everybody was scrambling
to do coverage.
And so these editors called
me down to this big boardroom
with all these books
and leather-bound books
and couches.
And what they
wanted to ask me is
if I thought it was
OK if they referred
to those affected by
Hurricane Katrina as refugees.
So I was like, OK, hmm.
First of all, let me tell you
that I cannot exonerate you,
no matter what you do.
I like to think of
myself as very regal,
but I'm not the
queen of blackness.
There's nothing-- you know,
no wand I can wave and say,
this is what you should do,
and you won't get in trouble.
But I will answer your
question with a question.
If something happened in Iowa,
or Idaho, or here in Chicago,
would you refer to the
people affected as refugees?
And they immediately said no.
So I'm glad they asked.
I'm not grateful
that they asked.
They should ask.
But I'm glad that they
asked and that I was there
to talk to them about
this because it could
have been a very big misstep.
But I think that's what
brings us here today is
that because there were
so few people there,
up in those higher
echelons, they honestly
were going to go with that
had I not said anything.
And it did occur to them
to ask, which is important.
But the fact is, that
they couldn't come up
with a consensus without
asking me is another issue.
So you might
recognize this frame.
So media is definitely failing
its multicultural audiences.
And this is "Dear White
People," which, by the way,
is very good on Netflix, if
you haven't seen the show.
And I don't think
that this is a point
that we can go over too much.
I think people believe
sometimes that there's just
like this small, dissenting
minority of people
who want to see all
this positive news
about multicultural groups.
And I really don't
think that's true.
I think people just want to see
factual, accurate reporting.
They want to see nuance.
They want to see stories
that are not just crime,
or stories that are not
just about race or politics.
They want to see
stories that reflect
the American population.
So when I say that to
people, sometimes they think,
well, you know, there's
been some progress.
But the fact of
the matter is there
hasn't been enough
progress, considering
the American population,
which I'll go into.
So what I've done with
the presentation is
I have put some
factoids in here,
because I think when you're
telling personal stories,
people kind of get it.
But I think if you see numbers,
then people totally get it.
So this one is "don't sleep,"
and for obvious reasons.
I think we take a lot
of things for granted,
especially in America,
regarding our population.
But in just five
years, about 50.2%
of children born in the United
States will be minorities.
So the whole definition
of minority is changing.
In 2020, white children
will be the minority
in the United States.
And this is according
to the census.
And then in 2060-- now,
this is really jarring--
62% of the population
that identifies as white
will drop all the way
down to about 44%.
So when you see these
newsrooms-- and things
are changing in certain areas.
But when you go to a lot of
traditional newsrooms, what you
will see is white older males.
And that does not at all
reflect the population.
So there are issues
and things that
are lost in translation
because of that.
And I know this
as well as anyone.
You would love to believe
that maybe media coverage will
change because people
are just awesome.
And people are awesome.
But it's not just
altruism that's
going to get us
to this next area.
So I think it's
important for people
to realize what the
potential of this market is.
And so I'll just go over
a couple of the stats
that I have here.
But for example,
magazines, I came
from the magazine industry.
We all know that print
magazines are not
doing very well just
because the advertising
model has shifted so much.
But of the mainstream
population,
which 55% are reading magazines,
minority populations read 65%.
So there's an over-index there.
In terms of radio, everybody
talks about the death of radio
when you've got
podcasts, we've got
all of these
technologies coming out.
However, minority
communities are
listening to 20
hours of radio a week
compared to 10 hours for just
the mainstream population.
In terms of apps,
watching videos,
which is another really
important area also
for advertising-- people are
always slipping those little
videos in there--
56 hours a month, that's
what black citizens alone
are watching on their apps.
They're 81% more
likely to show support
for a brand, which is super
important, because we always
talk about brand
influencers and people
that can tout your
brand, especially
in a crowded marketplace.
And this is extremely
important to note.
76% will share their opinions
on some of the social media
outlets.
So I think that's
important to think about,
because when things
don't go right,
it can be an ugly situation.
I'm sure we've all heard
the term Black Twitter,
and we've all heard
about dragging.
And it is a real thing.
I've only been kind of dragged
once, like just a light tug.
But I can promise you that I
don't want any more of that.
So I definitely advise
against being dragged.
Another reason that
African-American audience
is important is
that it's becoming
a more educated community.
Household income is increasing.
I think because we see so many
of these stories and headlines
that talk about what isn't
going right-- you know,
the crime rates or issues
with Black Lives Matter,
because of that, there is
almost like a blind spot
with the mainstream media when
it comes to this population.
And that is why I
believe there is
so much story ideation around
these negative developments.
And I do miss President Obama.
Sorry, I had to say that.
I know.
Everyone's going aw.
So 75%-- I think
this is horrible.
75% of African-Americans
distrust the media
that they read.
So if you think about it--
and that's insulting to me,
actually, as somebody who
went to school for this,
worked hard on fact checking.
For me to be writing something
when I was maybe in more
of a mainstream outlet--
I don't think I
experienced this as
much when I was at a
black-owned publication.
For somebody to be giving me
the side eye to the rate of 75%,
that is extremely high.
And I think that
demonstrates that this is not
a problem that is just among
a small group of people.
This is widespread.
And I'll tell you why.
And I have some examples.
The funny thing is, whenever
I talk about this topic,
it takes me two seconds
to find a new example.
I wish I could bring
you an example from 2016
and say, oh, this is
back in the bad old days.
No.
I have a very fresh
example for you.
So I won't go
through all of these
because I really do
want to get to talking
to everybody about
this issue and what
your thoughts are on it.
But I'll just highlight
a few, the ones that make
me the most physically ill.
We'll start with
Miss Kardashian.
No shade to the Kardashian clan.
They are doing their thing.
However, Kim Kardashian by
no means invented cornrows.
The fact that a
magazine would put out
a story saying that she
created this trend called
boxer braids, which basically is
the way my mother used to braid
my hair when I would swim when
I was like seven years old,
I was like, this is a slap.
I mean, did you do any research?
Did you ask anyone?
Have you ever been anywhere?
Because that, to
me, was so galling.
And I think it really
offends individuals.
I have in the
audience here today
Wendy Wilson, who's one of
my colleagues from "Ebony."
And we talked about that.
In the fashion
industry in particular,
it seems like there is just this
blindness towards black women.
And this is an example of it.
Here's another one that made
me irate, when "The New York
Times" referred to Viola Davis
as not classically beautiful.
According to who?
Did they not see her
at the Golden Globes
when she was serving
with her yellow dress?
I mean, just the
nerve of someone
to come up with
something like that.
And when you say
"classically beautiful,"
you understand what
the implication is.
What does that mean?
That she's not blonde,
that she's not--
what are you saying when
you talk about that?
No, she does not necessarily
look like Scarlett Johansson.
But is there not
room in the spectrum
for her to be considered
beautiful as well?
The Mike Brown
situation in Ferguson,
when the news outlets-- and
again, I don't think this
was purposeful.
I think it was because they
were racing against the clock.
You're trying to
get new information.
But a lot of the
stories show the image
on the left, if you can see it,
where he's putting up his hand.
And I don't necessarily think it
is a gang symbol or something,
but there is somewhat
of an implication there.
And then on the right, you
see him just living his life.
Or you could have used
the graduation picture.
You could have used
something else.
The bottom line is that
a lot of media outlets
hit back and said, hey, we
were under a time crunch.
This is the picture that we had.
We had to run with it.
However, I think it's obvious
that, in many cases, when there
is a story about a white teen,
even in a similar situation,
they will get a graduation
picture, a picture with family,
something that doesn't have any
sort of a negative connotation.
And people notice that.
And it actually started
a trending topic
on the aforementioned Black
Twitter of what photo will
they use when I die.
Because any one of us
has taken a picture
that we might not necessarily
want to see again.
And to use that as the
photo, it does definitely
sway public opinion.
And I can admit to you, the
outlet that I was working with,
we were in the same position.
We did use that photo because
honestly, when I looked at it,
I didn't see it as being
in any way nefarious.
But once the public said hey,
guys, this picture is bad,
please take this down or
find something else, we did.
The issue was when
people say something
or when the public speaks
out and then no one responds.
And then this is my fave.
Oh, boy.
So we recently had the
revelation that how
to show natural
hairstyles, though I
don't know if you can see the
picture on the bottom right.
They had a story
about how to rock
natural hairstyles in PopSugar.
And every single woman
in this story was white.
Now, I understand that
all hair is natural
when it comes down to it.
Unless you're growing some kind
of acrylic out of your head,
everything is natural.
But black women have
clearly taken this term
and were using it
for the purpose
that we have not traditionally
been able to wear our hair
as it grows out of our heads
in a traditional workplace.
I mean, there's
still legislation
that allows you to fire
someone if they have locks.
So we're not at a place where
we can all lives matter hair.
So when this
publication did this,
the retribution was swift.
But my question was, why
did you ever do this?
If you had just had
somebody around, somebody
diverse in your circle, this
never would have happened.
Some of these things
are totally avoidable.
And that's the issue.
And the last one
I'll point out--
and this is because,
again, I don't think this
is malicious, but
extremely hurtful
that "Cosmo" did
a lineup of trends
that were dead, like RIP,
goodbye, you ugly trend.
And then they had
"Hello, gorgeous,"
and they were ushering in
the new beautiful trends.
And about 90% of the
goodbye, ugly trend
were black women and
models, Joan Smalls.
Like, it was terrible.
But I don't think-- again,
it was not done deliberately.
But-- and they
apologized for it.
But the fact is, no one looked
at this lineup and thought,
this could be a problem?
That is the problem.
So again, sad that
the examples continue.
So what are we looking for?
Naomi's clapping it up for us.
We are looking for
fair representation.
No one is looking
to be treated better
than anyone, just like
you don't want to be
treated worse than anyone.
What we're looking for is even
simple issues-- stock art.
And I had this happen.
I will not name the agency.
But one day, just
out of curiosity,
I decided to do a search in
this popular stock art agency's
collection.
And I put in the word "ghetto."
If I didn't get back every
black person known to man
that was in their catalog--
I could not believe it.
I mean, and this
happened in 2016.
Most of the images are
of people of non-color.
It's very hard to find any sort
of minority in the stock art.
And it's being remedied
within the community.
I know several women, for
example, who started agencies
where they take
pictures, and they
make it available
to the media's use
so that there are these
different images out there.
But the sad fact is that
in these major agencies,
there's only a very tiny,
microscopic selection
you have to choose from.
And that's why if
you look, you'll
notice that you see
the same feature
images in a lot of stories.
And that is why,
because there just
are not a lot of images of
people of color, period,
not just African-Americans.
I think asking people to be
part of stories that are not
about race, that are not
about class, that are not
about politics, asking people
questions about riding bikes.
You know, I ride bikes,
somewhat, not very well,
but I do.
I would like to be
interviewed for stories
that don't necessarily
base upon the way
that I look as a person.
Like, we're all humans.
We're all Americans.
And we're all global citizens.
Why shouldn't we be
included in other stories?
Being authentic in it, showing
people just because it's cool--
for example, I think sometimes
people fixate on a certain pop
culture citizen.
Like this is an unpopular
topic right now,
but a Blac Chyna, for example,
or something like that.
And the people just
discovered who this.
It's like, come on, now.
You know?
And they go all in.
And they give them covers,
and they give them this.
And it just rings false because
it's obvious that you're not
interested in anyone else.
You're just interested
in specific black people
that are undeniably
popular at the moment.
And otherwise, this
wouldn't be something
that you would
work very hard at.
So that can be a huge problem.
I think even what I learned
when I was in school,
that the professors always
told us, interviewing a lawyer
or interviewing a
professor, make an effort,
especially if it's not a
story based around race,
to talk to people of different
areas of the spectrum
because you want to
mirror the populace.
And I think that, unfortunately,
because people are in a rush
and they have these circles
of people that they talk to,
they just want to
continue in that vein.
But I think we just really have
to ask ourselves to expand.
And there are publications that
are doing a much better job.
Because I don't like to
keep it all negative,
I want to talk about some
good success stories.
"Washington Post" has been
doing an incredible job.
"Huffington Post, Black
Voices" does a great job
with a small staff.
They're able to cover
a lot of issues.
They have a lot of op-eds.
But they also do really good
investigative reporting.
They stress the importance of
covering the black community
across the diaspora.
"Buzzfeed" is doing
a really good job.
And what I really want
to commend them for
is transparency.
What I have run into as
a member of the National
Association of
Black Journalists is
that news outlets don't want to
tell you who they have there.
Like, we're a group of
people that are always
asking questions, but
this is a question
that we don't want to answer.
So you don't know what
the proportions are.
Even when they do
surveys, there's
a low return of organizations
that will provide background.
So "Buzzfeed" did that.
They talk about how
many people they have.
They talk about black.
They talk about Asian.
They talk about women.
They let people know
what they're doing.
And yes, you open
yourself up to criticism.
Someone could look at that and
say, well, that's not enough.
But the bottom line is, I think
that if you open yourself up
to that criticism, it shows
that you are willing to fix it.
When you hide it,
it makes it seem
like you want to keep
things in the status quo.
And I think another important
question for us to ask--
I know that, as I said,
Google is extremely important.
But even just as individuals,
we can do things.
Something that I
just did recently--
and I'm just using
my own example
because I don't want to
put anyone else out there
on Front Street necessarily.
But a friend of a friend of
mine went into a 7-Eleven
in Chicago.
She was a mother.
She sent her two boys that
were teenagers, like, very
young boys, into the store to
pick up food for their lunch.
And within minutes, they were
back outside with nothing.
And she asked them
what happened.
And the little boys,
they just said, you know,
it's no problem.
He just didn't want us in
there because we're black.
It's OK.
And she was like, wait a minute.
What?
That is not OK.
She took them back in the store.
She asked the clerk what he did.
And I think he told on himself
because when asked about it,
he said something to her
to the effect of well,
I'm an American.
Like what-- is this
an immigration office?
It's a 7-Eleven.
You know what I mean?
Like, what does
living in America
have to do with anything.
But that little video of
her encountering this man
and really confronting him
about what he did to her sons,
I posted it.
I encouraged a lot of
other people to post it.
News outlets got into it.
And from what I understand, he
was removed from that store.
So there are things
that we as individuals
can do with the
power of smartphones,
with the power of social media.
If we see things
that we don't like,
there's something that
we can do in response.
Back in the day, there was
the letter to the editor.
That could take
months to surface.
And the reaction would be
equally slow, very glacial.
But now, I think there's
an immediate reaction.
Now, you don't want
to jump the gun.
Everything is not
a racial situation.
But I think it is
extremely important
that we take our voices
and that we channel those
into positive change.
Because the bottom line
is that, as I said,
the demographic is changing.
The country is changing.
The globe is changing.
And the last thing
we want to do is
have the media that's supposed
to be a catalyst for revolution
be the one that's putting
down the revolution.
So that's pretty much everything
that I wanted to say to you.
And I'd love to
hear what you have
to say to me about the topic.
I know it can be hot
button, and sometimes people
can be a little fearful
about bringing up the issues,
but I think that's the
only way that we'll ever
come to a solution.
So thank you so much
for your attention.
I appreciate it
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank
you so much, Kyra.
You have a powerful voice
and such a strong message.
And it is a tough topic.
But with staggering
statistics like this,
we have to bring change.
And it doesn't come quick.
It doesn't come easy.
It's been a long time coming.
But by having this
conversation here today
and the impact that you've had
in the industry, it's a start.
And there are ways that
we can also take action.
KYRA KYLES: Yes.
SPEAKER: I'd like to just start
learning a little bit more
about you.
KYRA KYLES: Sure.
SPEAKER: Just how did
you get in the industry?
You had an accelerated master's
program at Northwestern.
You dove right into journalism.
What sparked that interest?
KYRA KYLES: You
know, I've always
been interested in writing,
ever since I was a little kid.
I often tell the
story that my mom
used to occupy my time when
I was a child by putting me
in front of a
dressing room mirror.
And I would sit there and
do these little broadcasts
so she could shop,
shop, shop, and I
would be doing the weather
and talking about the news.
I even had a "Barbie"
magazine with my sister
that we forced my
poor father to read.
He'd come home from
work exhausted and have
this terrible magazine printed
out and ready for him to read.
So it's funny because,
oftentimes, people
say they want to be something
when they were little,
and then that
doesn't materialize.
So in my case, that is
exactly what happened.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
And you veered into
the print media.
You're heavily involved
in multi-platform,
and you've kind of dabbled
in each form, if you will.
On this topic of diversity
and the topic of media,
are there some subverticals
that are doing it better
than others, whether
it's broadcast,
primetime, newspapers, digital?
KYRA KYLES: I would
say, just by design--
because digital typically,
it's a younger workforce.
It's more malleable.
There aren't these entrenched
employees and entrenched ways
of doing things-- digital
seems to be leading the way.
For example, I believe
it's about double
the number of women working for
some of these online outlets
compared to your
traditional dailies.
So they are far and
beyond leading the way.
And I think they've
actually worked collectively
to bring up the statistics
of the number of minorities
in media when added with
these traditional outlets.
TV, I believe, is among the
slowest, if I'm not mistaken.
And that's probably because
it's a visual medium.
We still have situations--
I don't know if most of you saw
the story about the woman who
does the weather who she
got all these nasty viewer
notes because she was wearing
her natural hair on air.
And I mean, the
things that people
said, you would
have thought we'd
climbed into a time machine and
gone back, the 1950s or '60s.
Because it's a visual
medium, it may be harder
to adjust and to
embrace those trends.
And viewers are
older, so they're
used to seeing certain things.
So if they wake up
and they see someone
that doesn't look like
what they're used to,
they'll turn it off.
And because it's such
a delicate situation--
they need that
advertising model--
they still continue to follow
the audience in that way.
So I think unless you had a
lot of young people tuning
in and voicing
concerns about what
they're seeing,
that one is one that
will continue to be stagnant.
And also, behind the scenes
is extremely important.
A lot of people see
people on the front lines.
They don't see the directors,
the producers, the writers
behind the scenes on TV.
That is also not very diverse.
And in newspapers, you can
kind of tell a little bit more.
But again, you don't necessarily
know the background of people
that you're reading.
But just statistically
speaking, as I understand it,
it's about 17% of the
total news workforce,
of those who responded,
are minorities
at this moment, people of color.
SPEAKER: So with
such low numbers,
how can we bring change?
Does it count just being--
I'll share a little bit
about the Google practices.
Because it's not just
at the hiring stage,
it's also in the inclusion.
Diversity and
inclusion is something
that's one of our pillars
and values at this company.
Work to be done.
And that's because
also in working
on the pipeline of applicants.
So there's another pillar that's
really critical to Google,
which is in education,
inspiring the next generation
and thinking about
computer science.
And the last pillar
is our community.
How do we make sure
that we bring access
to everyone, training SMB,
small- and medium-sized
businesses, or others so that
they have the tools to grow.
How do we start bringing
more diverse voices
into the world of journalism?
Is it in the schools?
How would you think
about that approach?
KYRA KYLES: Yeah,
I definitely think
education is a critical
piece because you
do need that training in order
to go into journalism, though
nowadays, some of these sites,
you might question that.
But I think one
really important thing
is that it's still
kind of a privilege
to work in journalism.
People expect you
to work for free.
Some people can't afford to
do that, especially somebody,
a person of color, maybe
somebody who hasn't inherited
familial wealth.
They can't afford to
do a free internship.
I've had situations when I
was working with "Ebony" where
someone was working in
retail and also coming in,
but they didn't have
enough hours to really make
a significant difference.
I think that paying interns
a decent amount would help,
because that would give them
impetus to join the field
and to be trained the right way.
And also to then get advocates
from within the industry that
can reach back and say, hey, I
had this really great intern.
Here's a role that
this person could fill.
People always hire from
within their circle.
I think that's
across the industry.
And if you don't know
people, you cannot hire them.
If you've never met
them because they've
had to work a regular
job because they
can't afford to work for free--
it's a moot point to talk
about diversity if you're not
doing those things.
And that goes across the board.
Even in Hollywood,
people can't afford
to work for free for agents
and that kind of thing.
And that's the reason why you
see some of the white-washing
that people talk
about in the movies.
I think also it's the audience.
I think the audience
has to demand better.
I think they have to call
people on the carpet.
I recently saw a horrible
industry article.
It was a review of the
movie, "Girls Trip."
I don't know what happened here.
It was just really
pointed and really biased.
And instead of evaluating it
like you would "Bridesmaids,"
this author decided to
compare this movie that
has nothing to do with anything
to Tyler Perry's movies.
And I think it was because that
was his frame of reference.
And that would be like
comparing the Coen
Brothers to Seth MacFarlane.
It doesn't make sense.
So I think it is about exposure.
It's about audience
driving change.
And it is about supporting
journalists of color.
When you see them and
they're doing great work,
support them on social media.
Follow them.
Get more familiar
with their work
so that they can be touted.
We've had several
journalists who have
gotten that kind of treatment.
And it really helps.
And I think we just have
to continue in that vein.
It's not one bullet solution.
It's like a comprehensive
change that we're
going to have to see.
SPEAKER: Beautiful.
The need to have stronger
and more inclusive
journalism voices, I think
there is a stat on your side,
about 75% of African-Americans
actually trust
the source of news.
KYRA KYLES: That they don't.
SPEAKER: Don't trust.
KYRA KYLES: Not, right.
SPEAKER: So what happens?
Is there just no
more readership?
Or do they turn to
different sources?
I mean, what--
KYRA KYLES: I think
people continue
to read because this
is the information.
But I think they take
it with a huge grain
of salt. They think, OK,
the police are always
right in these
stories that I read.
The person that's killed or hurt
or put in jail is always wrong.
I think that there has also
been a proliferation of blogs
and different sites.
And I would say, for example,
like "Very Smart Brothas,"
"The Root."
They're in different areas.
Some are entertainment,
"Shadow and Act,"
that have come to
fill in these gaps.
And I think they're
very successful.
But because they still
aren't the juggernauts
that some of these
other sites are--
You know, "BET" has
a huge audience,
and so their news
really infiltrates.
But some of these smaller
sites may be aggregated.
They have influence.
But they're still not going
to have the heft of, say,
the Tribune company, which has
all these different affiliates.
So I do believe it's
bringing forth new voices.
But I still think bringing
forth new voices is effective,
but it would be
even more effective
if we could get
some of those voices
into the traditional outlets
that people read the most.
And some of those people that
read the traditional outlets
are the main ones that
need to read the new voices
because they're
just indoctrinated
in what they're accustomed to.
And sometimes that's
very biased information.
SPEAKER: It's true.
If we look at another industry,
the movies industry, what
happened with the
Oscars last year,
it was pretty blatant in terms
of the lack of diversity.
And one approach
they took-- and I
don't know if it's the right
one for other industries
to look at.
But they set a number
in terms of how--
they wanted to elevate the
number by 2020, I think it was,
of women and African-American
and Latino writers.
What's your perspective on that?
KYRA KYLES: I think
that's a good step.
Again, I do think it also has
to be within the rank and file.
It has to be the producers.
It has to be the script writers.
There have to be more
people behind the scenes,
the directors, the
cinematographers,
in order to really
make sure that we're
seeing movies that reflect
the audience that's
sitting in front of it.
I mean, I'll say, I've
been reading recently--
and I am a huge "Game
of Thrones" fan.
I once broke up with
a person because they
kept talking during the scenes.
I'm like, no, you're gonna
be quiet or we're done here.
But I mean, it is weird that in
this fantasy world where there
are dragons and White
Walkers and zombie horses,
you can envision maybe three,
four people of color, period.
And it's weird to people.
I think you're
coming into a time
where people are not
willing to accept that.
And then on the reverse,
we have the "Black Panther"
trailers came out, and
people lost their minds.
What is happening here?
Why wasn't there a role
set aside for Matt Damon?
I'm not going to go see this.
And it's like, listen,
Matt Damon had his turn
when he was on the Great Wall
of China for reasons unknown.
We're going to let that go.
We're going to let Matt Damon
take a bench on this one.
But I think that it's got
to come from everywhere.
Having the judges have
more diversity, which
is what they did, is great.
But if there aren't more
movies, it's still not
going to solve anything.
We need more movies out
with people of color behind
as well as in front
of the scenes.
We do have good visibility
in front of the camera,
and that's getting
better, especially on TV.
I think television is
really doing a great job.
But the industries are old,
and they're showing their age.
And I think we're now
starting to come up
against a generation that's not
willing to just accept that.
They're going to say,
hey, if you don't make it,
we'll go make it ourselves.
That's why you saw the
success of "Get Out."
That movie, I don't think
it could have been made,
like, five or six years ago.
And now, because of the
response it's getting,
you'll see more provocative
films like that.
You know, everything is not--
I respect Tyler Perry because
he's doing amazing things.
But everything is
not Tyler Perry,
and nor should it have to be.
And that shouldn't
be the framework
by which movies with a black
cast or black executives
is judged.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
It's a shared responsibility,
from corporations
to also the talent
producing the movies.
And it was a colleague
of mine who pointed out
that Disney's
"Mulan" movie, they
were about to cast a white
male to be the love interest.
And it was a petition of 90,000
folks signed in to make a stop.
And then they
changed the writers.
So there is a way to
have a voice for people.
KYRA KYLES: There is.
Yeah, and to have
an immediate voice.
And I think that's
important, because there
used to be a time it would have
been a letter-writing campaign
or something, which is very
sluggish and ineffective.
The movie would have
been in the theaters
by the time people
knew about the protest.
I think that-- as you point out,
that is a terrible thing to do.
Why would you do that?
And there really
is a galling lack
of Asian representation
in movies and pop culture
in general.
You're starting to see more
of that, but not enough.
They can't afford to
do that at this point.
And I'm so glad that
people spoke out.
And I hope that teaches them a
lesson because I wanted to see
"Ghost in the Shell,"
but I couldn't.
Because even though
Scarlett Johansson is, like,
one of my Women Crush
Wednesdays, I could not do it.
Because it's such a huge
opportunity that you miss.
And I think people
need to understand.
They may ignore a
protest, but when
they see the box
office numbers drop,
there's no way to ignore that.
And Hollywood is
driven by money.
So is the media.
So if you speak with your
dollars and you don't invest,
they will figure out a
different way to do things.
They always have.
SPEAKER: I'm going to ask
you one last question,
and then we'll open it up.
And we've got some
mics here if you
want to start lining
up with the questions
that you're dying to ask Kyra.
But it's a little
bit more about--
we opened up with who are you.
I want to also ask you a topic
that's come up out of our Ann
Arbor office.
And it is a series, "First
time I discovered I was black."
And that was a Googler
who thought of the series,
created and produced
a 30-minute video
segment inspired by what he'd
seen on CNN of the same title.
When was the first time you
realized you were black?
KYRA KYLES: It was
a wonderful day.
I can remember that much.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, I think I
was exposed early.
I would say maybe the context
of color and race and that,
maybe when I was
about four or five,
because I grew up in
a predominantly Irish
neighborhood.
And my mother really
didn't have a choice.
There were children
playing with the hair
and rubbing on the skin.
And I was like,
what are they doing?
They would ask us why
our dolls were this,
because my mother bought us
black dolls because she wanted
to reinforce our beauty ideals.
So we had some
beautiful black dolls.
Like, one looked
like Phylicia Rashad.
They were so pretty.
And the fact that
we had them often
caused questions from the
kids in the neighborhood.
So I believe as early as
that, I figured it out.
And then my mother
talked to us about it,
talked about the differences,
talked about history
to us in a way that we could
understand and consume.
So I felt luckier than
some other children
when I went to school
and they really weren't
aware of our history and that.
And they seemed to be more
subject to being, like, shamed
for being different.
Whereas with me,
I was like, you're
just mad because your
hair doesn't do this.
You know?
So you know, I had a different
and much more positive
feeling about it than
if I had come in there
and been surprised.
You and I were
talking earlier today
about the sportscaster
who said that he
doesn't know what he is, and
race doesn't matter anyway.
And I mean, I feel like this
is a man that he probably
should know at this point.
He's about 50 years old.
If he's passed at least three
mirrors, he should know.
[LAUGHTER]
But the fact that that's
still happening though,
that just tells you how fraught
with controversy the topic is.
Identification and
embracing your culture,
it's still something that
is not easy for anyone.
SPEAKER: For sure.
But shouldn't you be
able to hear the voice
that you had such a
beautiful narrative growing
up and hearing that
story, and being
able to project your
voice and to read
about like-minded
voices as well?
KYRA KYLES: Exactly, right.
And I think that's
extremely important.
In the black community
and people of color,
I think there is a saying.
It's like, you have
to see it to be it.
Seeing even President Barack
Obama ascend that way,
kids my age probably
didn't think
that that could happen
just based on the way
that society is set up.
But there is
generations of children
that for them, that's a goal.
They don't even
think twice about it
because they've seen it.
And it's sad that we just
need to see more examples.
And then people
being free to talk
about them in various outlets
and in movies and TV and pop
culture.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
You sparked some
ideas as well as
to how we can do that--
sponsorship and others.
KYRA KYLES: Wonderful.
SPEAKER: We'll turn to some
live questions and pass it over.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you so much, Kyra, for
coming and speaking with us.
KYRA KYLES: Of course.
AUDIENCE: So we've heard several
women, female executives,
of color come and see us
and share their experiences.
Some of them actually
expressed that they
felt more discrimination
as a woman
than as a person of color.
So I'd love to get
your experiences.
Does that align to
your expectations
and your experiences
and what you've
seen in the media industry?
Or what's the situation there?
KYRA KYLES: For me,
personally-- and again,
this is just for me personally--
I feel that blackness cannot
be extracted from my womanness.
I feel like they're one thing.
Black women in general
are treated differently
than white women are treated.
I don't have the statistics
with me at the moment.
But just in terms of
being in a workplace
and having internal
advocates, black women
felt much less supported
than white women.
Now, white women felt much
less supported than white men.
So it's like the
old saying, it's
like there are levels to this.
So I think that when I come
into a room, people see a woman.
But I think first and
foremost, a lot of times,
they see a black woman.
I don't think I'm able to--
I'm a woman now and
also a black-- you know?
So I can only speak to mine.
But I think I like it because
I think I find it empowering.
Like, that's a double challenge
that I'm facing in society.
And for me to be able to make
it as far as I've made it
and be able to sit here and
address you all, I mean,
I hope that inspires
other young black girls.
I hope that inspires people.
I don't want to make light of
the challenges that I've faced
and say, oh, no it's
no problem, because I
don't want other people who
are experiencing problems
to think that they
are being singled out.
No, it's a problem usually.
But my hope is
that by doing this
and by talking to more people,
it will be less of a problem
until it's not a problem at all.
So that's the goal.
But that's an
excellent question.
And I'm sure there are different
people that would answer it
differently too.
SPEAKER: There's this
concept of allies at Google,
because no matter
how you identify,
you can have sponsors
in the room to make sure
that your voice is heard.
And I think it's something
that is work in progress here
and that we're also trying
to influence in the world.
But with beautiful leaders--
KYRA KYLES: And I think
that's super important.
I mean, and I love that that's
a priority because I think
sometimes we take for granted
that if you work somewhere,
you'll get a mentor.
They'll just appear to
you out of thin air.
No, people have to step up.
And I think that that's great
that you're encouraging that.
So that's terrific.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name's Jonathan.
And first, I just
want to thank you
for taking the time
to speak with us.
It's been a really
powerful message.
Throughout your career,
you've had the opportunity
to work at a number
of institutions,
large and small, some
that have gotten it right,
some that continued
to get it wrong.
And you gave all
those examples earlier
where it was almost like,
how could this happen?
How could you get to this
point in your creative process
or in your execution and
no one asked the question?
And the checks and
balances oftentimes
came from the public.
I would love to know,
in your experience, what
are some of the hallmarks of
institutions that get it right?
And what are some of
the checks and balances
they establish
internally to make
sure that the product
that they put out
is more reflective,
is more diverse?
KYRA KYLES: Well, that's
a fantastic question.
And I'll say, to
be fair, obviously,
it's not just the
media industry.
I mean, we all saw that
tone deaf Kylie Jenner Pepsi
ad where she solved Black
Lives Matter's issues
with a carbonated beverage.
And somebody bought
space for that.
And only until people
said, what are you doing,
did they pull the commercial.
I never would have aired it.
It was like a "Saturday Night
Live" sketch waiting to happen.
Like, you did Lorne
Michael's work for him.
SPEAKER: Beyonce is black?
KYRA KYLES: Right.
Yeah, well, that wax
figure, have you seen that?
They have her looking--
OK, but anyway, we'll
talk about that later.
[LAUGHTER]
But I would say, in terms
of checks and balances,
I think it's important to have
people of different backgrounds
with different
experiences in the room.
Unfortunately, especially
in the United States,
I think we have a
lot of segregation
at work and at home.
We have a lot of segregation
in terms of who we talk to.
So maybe some of these
people didn't have a friend
that they could say, hey,
we're doing something at work,
and it's going to be pretty big.
I'd like to get
your thoughts on it.
They may not have had that.
So if you don't have that
in your friends circle,
you should have it at work.
And I think what you also
need, which is super important,
is you need to have people of
color in the leadership roles
too.
Because there are sometimes
people in the room, and they're
intimidated to speak.
Like, when I got called in
there for that Hurricane Katrina
conversation, I did
think, they all seemingly
have made up their mind that
it's OK to use this term
"refugee."
I might end up
getting in trouble.
And I might jeopardize a
promotion in the future
by being that girl that
came in here and told them
what was what.
But my great-grandmother
marched with Martin Luther King.
I could not-- and I'm not saying
that like I'm some martyr,
because guess what?
I would have gotten
another job, I'm sure.
But I couldn't do it.
Because I couldn't be the one--
I actually had
readers call me when
they would see things
wrong in the newspaper--
how did you sit up there
and let that happen?
So I also had that
responsibility too.
And I had to tell
them, you know, guys,
I can't control everything.
But I did take my
responsibility seriously.
Some of it is not only just
having people in the room,
empowering them to speak,
and also having them
at different levels
of the company,
not just in the creative
and out-front fields,
but behind the scenes so that
they can stop it before it
even, as you mentioned, gets so
far up in the creative process
that you're already casting
for Kylie's police officer
she's going to
hand the Pepsi to.
They should never have--
no, that should never
happened, honestly.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
KYRA KYLES: No problem.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so you
mentioned fragmentation
and how people have
a great ability
to control what they see
and who they interact with.
Do you think the
media landscape is
getting a lot more fragmented
these days in terms of people
being able to self-select more
and more specific outlets?
And do you think
that's going to present
a big problem for the types
of issues we're talking about?
KYRA KYLES: Well,
I think it already
presented a big problem.
I think it has a lot to do
with our election results,
to be honest.
I mean, and not to
get super political,
but there is proof that people
reading erroneous information,
people reading kind
of race baiting,
or just plain not
factual information
had an effect on the
way people voted,
had an effect on the way
people came out to vote.
And I think we do live in a time
where you could be in a bubble
if you want to, if
you decide to wake up
and use one news
source for everything
and only go to those
things that agree with you.
Like I'll admit, in my little
circle of Facebook friends,
most of us agree.
When someone doesn't,
it's really jarring.
But that's actually
not a great thing
because then you're
being reinforced
and you think what
you're doing is right.
You don't have any
educated dissenter.
I'm not talking about a troll.
I'm talking about
somebody who really knows
what they're talking about.
We are seeing more
consolidation of news entities
teaming up and working together.
Because of the
lack of resources,
they almost have
to work together.
But I do think-- that's what
I'm kind of afraid of is
that people will become so
disenchanted with the way
that the traditional media
is that they will just say,
I'm not going to
read that anymore.
I'm just going to rely
on this small blog
with like three people that
don't have enough people to do
an investigative bureau.
And I'm going to go
with whatever they say.
So I think it is a problem.
But we can head that off by
bringing some of those voices
into the mainstream
in larger outlets.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
You touch on an issue with
the cost of journalism
and needing to be able
to sponsor and fund
quality journalism.
But when we look at the
numbers and shifts, where
in terms of the minority
will become the majority,
those ad dollars will
need to be invested.
There was a question
that came in from one
of the colleagues, which
was, when you think
of the traditionally
black publications,
their voices really
focus on their audience.
With the shift in
demographics, how
do you see that evolution
for those publications,
the "Ebonys,"
"Jets," of the world?
KYRA KYLES: That's
a great question.
So I can say from my
personal experience
and what I observed--
and Wendy and Melissa,
yell out if I'm incorrect.
They worked with me at
"Ebony" when I was there.
Sometimes advertisers
seem to believe
that they can get advertising
in these black publications
investing less than they
would for a mainstream outlet,
even if they see that the
numbers that they're getting
are very similar.
And I think that's
another systemic issue,
the fact that you think you
should pay less for the same.
So that is a problem.
And it's hard to really
get hardcore with them
because then they can
take their dollars
and invest digitally with some
of these outlets that may not
be as established,
but it doesn't cost
as much to invest that way.
But again, journalism does cost
money, good journalism does.
You can't do investigations.
You can't be thorough.
Sure, you can write a
lot of opinion pieces
that are based in existing fact.
But you can't do
any deep digging
if you don't have money.
So that is an
important thing and one
that I think that the technology
industry could assist with.
If they could fund
certain initiatives,
if they could help maybe
invest in investigative arms,
or invest in certain
investigations, period,
I think that that
would be helpful.
It's a very difficult question
because one would think that
the shift in demographics
would mean a shift in budget,
but it hasn't.
And a lot of people
point to the fact
that yes, there are
niche black publications.
But I grew up reading all
the different magazines too.
I even had a situation--
this was very recent-- where
I went to a car dealership--
spoiler alert, I
did not buy the car
because I did not like
this guy's attitude.
He said to me--
I told him where I worked.
At the time, it was "Ebony."
He came up with this
wonderful anecdote,
trying to relate to me.
He was like, you know what?
You're going to
think this is funny.
I was like, oh, my god.
I know I'm not going
to think it's funny.
He said to me that he loved
Will Smith when he was a kid.
He would buy Will
Smith on anything.
Didn't matter what it was.
He saw an "Ebony" magazine
with Will Smith on it.
He goes, so here I am, this kid.
I get up there and I
buy an "Ebony" magazine.
And I was like, and
the punch line is what?
And I was like, every day
that I buy a magazine,
these are not black
magazines, the cashier
has never stopped me.
I don't get the story.
You know what?
Why don't we just go
back to the dealership?
And then I ended up buying
a totally different car.
But that's what I'm saying.
Like, there's still
this stigma and thought
that it'd be weird
for a person that's
not black to buy this
magazine, but it's not weird
for me to buy a magazine that
isn't black-owned and doesn't
have a black person
on the cover.
And this happened last year.
So it's not some ancient
tale I'm telling.
And that says a lot
about that situation.
SPEAKER: It's so unfortunate.
KYRA KYLES: It was, for
him and his sale too.
He learned something.
He won't tell that story again.
[LAUGHTER]
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Latoya.
I work on a team
called the News Lab.
And we are all about
working with journalists
and technologists to help
build the future of media.
I lead a piece of
work on the team
called Inclusive Storytelling.
How do we elevate the voices
that we don't traditionally
hear in media?
I'm just going to
point out one thing.
You mentioned that you need
sponsorships and dollars.
That's exactly what our team
does, trying to increase--
we support the Ida
B.Wells Society,
for instance, which is about
training journalists of colors
to be investigative journalists.
I wanted to ask you your
thoughts on what more
technology companies can do.
You made the point about
Pepsi and people of color
not having a seat
at the table and not
being in positions of
power to say something.
When we think about newsrooms,
I think we've seen the numbers.
The leadership, I think it's
86% of editorial directors
and so on are white men.
How do you change that?
What does it take to
shake up the newsrooms?
Is it a matter of just
hiring more people?
Going to find them?
What's the role a
technology company
can play in really
inspiring that change?
It's something we think about.
We don't have the answers.
But it seems that
change comes down
to getting more people
with a seat at the table.
But how do we make that happen?
KYRA KYLES: Well, I really
liked and was encouraged
by what Google is doing
with Howard University,
by creating this
space where people
of the university and students
are interacting directly
with Google employees, seeing
what their future can be,
seeing what the potential is.
Something to that effect in the
area of journalism, I think,
would be very impactful.
I do think, like
what you mentioned,
the Ida B. Wells,
that sounds amazing.
I also noted that
Google is going
to be a partner in evaluating
the number of minorities
in journalism for next
year, which is great.
Having that transparency
is extremely important
because how can we fix the
problem if we don't even
know the full scope of it.
Maybe using technology tools
to create job bank databases,
or helping create programs or
fellowships that pay a stipend.
As I mentioned the problem
about news entities
not paying or paying
below standard,
maybe in some way trying to
help boost that amount of pay
so that people can afford
to enter the industry.
And then training.
So NABJ offers amazing training
for managers and people
who want to go into
the management track,
supporting those efforts,
so that you don't just
have people who are the
writers and they get on CNN.
And yeah, everybody
knows them by name,
but they don't necessarily
have as much power
behind the scenes
as these producers
and these other people who
are telling them where to go
and what to do and
what to focus on.
So I think that
what you mentioned
is a great start, and just
continuing to do that.
And also making it easier to
find people or candidates,
it would be important.
I think technology is
very helpful in that it
connects people that might
not otherwise be connected.
But what I find that
it does a lot of times
is it just makes it easier
to connect with those
you already know.
And I would love to see
some technologies that
push you beyond that.
One of my mentors and
former managers, Jane Hurt,
that worked at the
Tribune red eye, what
I love about her is that she
would go out of her way to go
find people of
color people, people
representing different areas
of the gender Spectrum.
She did this with a
conscious thought--
this is what I'm doing--
and not in a way of,
this is a token hire.
But this is a
super-talented person.
I'm going to work
with this person.
I'm going to make sure
that they feel welcome.
And I'm going to make sure
that their voices are heard.
She will ask you, what do you
think about this, in a way that
doesn't make it feel like
you're being pigeonholed.
And I think it's also that, the
manager mindset of not bringing
someone in so you can
just take a staff picture
and look like you're
doing something,
but really making them
part of the process.
And she did that really well.
So I bring her up as an
example of what I would
love to see more managers do.
AUDIENCE: And I'll
be at NABJ in August.
KYRA KYLES: OK.
I'm sure you will, New Orleans.
All right, cool.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: So there is
this photo on the screen
that I have to ask,
what's the story?
KYRA KYLES: I just like
the way I look in it.
No, I'm just kidding.
So I went on "The Real"--
I think it was in
the end of last year,
in December, to
talk about-- which
is another important thing
and something that companies
can support.
"The Root" does their
own version of this.
A lot of entities do.
The Power 100 for
"Ebony" was a way
to highlight people that
are doing great things,
not just entertainment
and celebrity that you
see every day, but
people in technology,
people in nonprofit, people
in the business world.
And initiatives like that are
important because, again, it's
that see it to be it mentality.
So I was really
happy to go on there.
And the ladies were lovely.
They were very kind.
I didn't get to drink
whatever was in that mug.
I'm not sure what
it is to this day.
But yeah, it was a great
and empowering experience.
So I think we just need
more initiatives like that.
There are many people of
color across the globe doing
terrific things.
It saddens me that
sometimes those people
don't get the attention
that they deserve.
And I think that if we can work
on our media coverage, work
on our media newsrooms,
we will see more of that.
And the problem will
not vanish overnight.
But we will make a
lot more progress.
SPEAKER: We are
strong believers.
Our CEO has even said, a mix of
diverse perspective and ideas
and backgrounds will only lead
to better products and better
experiences.
And I'm hopeful.
I guess as a final
question, it would
be, what are you most excited
about for the next couple
of years?
KYRA KYLES: What I'm most
excited about is twofold.
So I'm excited by
people of color deciding
that they will invest and
create media outlets, TV
shows, that they will
showcase their talents,
and that they're doing
that, and that they're
getting a reception for that.
They're not waiting around.
They're not begging
people, please write me in,
or please cast me.
They're taking matters
into their own hands.
I think we're seeing a wave
of content creators of color
that are making a big splash.
It's not a niche thing.
It's not something that just a
handful of people are seeing.
You see that Issa Rae.
You see that with Donald Glover.
These are not people that
are just trying to be stars.
They're trying to make
opportunities for other people.
And I think that that's great.
Jordan Peele as well.
The other thing I'm
very excited about--
and some people in the
industry might disagree with me
on this-- is audience power.
I love that the audience can get
you right together really fast.
You know, when I
was in the newsroom,
I know people used to hate
when the phone would ring.
They'd hate emails
from the public.
I loved them.
Because that's how I
can do a better job.
How can I do a
better job if I have
no idea what the reception is?
There are some people who live
in this little ivory tower,
and they think that the
public doesn't have the savvy
to comment on what
they're doing?
But you're doing it for
them, so why can't they
have a two-way
conversation with you?
I love the fact that people
get dragged on Twitter.
Sometimes it's
funnier than others.
I think it's appropriate though.
You're putting
something out there.
You can't dictate to me
what I'm going to engage in,
or what I'm going
to like or hate.
And I love that.
So I think we're seeing power
to the people, so to speak,
and also power to the creators.
And that, I think,
is exhilarating.
And I'm excited to
watch where that goes.
SPEAKER: That's fantastic.
You've been an inspiring and
powerful and beautiful voice.
We're so lucky to have had
the opportunity to have
a conversation with you.
KYRA KYLES: It was
an honor to be here.
SPEAKER: You'll see another
friend later at the conference.
KYRA KYLES: Yes!
SPEAKER: Thank you again.
KYRA KYLES: All right.
Wonderful.
Thank you so much.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: It was so
great to see you.